guys reject nation welcome to
youtube.com slash the real rejects where
you're now watching this video my name
is John old M Humphrey and with me is my
home girl from another home girl school
we learned things but hey you must have
learned something cuz you just released
a movie I did o feature-length but
you're not even at like 75 minute you're
like an hour 45 dog hour 42 see I told
you I watched half of it you did I'm
gonna finish the other half this time
he's just drying it out as long as
possible because he doesn't want it to
end I don't this is the only time I'll
get to lay eyes on your feature for the
first time so I want to savor every
moment don't you only get the first time
once yeah plus I'm sitting there going
like which parts of this were inspired
by either events I participated in or
people that I know very well um and you
know a lot of it I was gonna say like
some of this seems familiar to me oh my
god that's so true yeah it's a lot of
you know like art imitating life
imitating art which is the way things
should be
you know hey you know what else is about
art imitating life
what comedies starring mark
[Music]
yeah you know I mean we were oh there's
a little bit mark in all of us you know
no fanfare let's do this what are you
gonna do
[Music]
a little bit of an
[Music]
yeah destruction I mean they haven't
given everything away because like what
happens they go to prison and never get
out of well the thing is this looks like
one of those movies that's gonna be like
slapstick for the first half and then
get like weirdly serious yeah I don't
know like just a couple of those shots
where they're like running to the
hospital and the girls crying and so
there's something about those gave me
that vibe of like this movie might get
unexpectedly serious yeah they're gonna
lure you in you're like oh this is a
feel-good movie and then they're gonna
make you cry and then you're gonna feel
good again yeah yeah which you know I
like when a movie can do a reversal like
that I guess the one thing that makes me
worry is all those slapstick get hit in
the face jokes
yeah like he keeps hitting that kid with
the ball and I understand that joke yeah
there are a couple things in there like
the very first scene it was like so
expositional why do you have five rooms
in this house you're never going to have
kids you are insane you'll never be able
to fill these up oh and then think about
it there's three kids that each get
their own room then they get their room
and they can sleep apart like a
traditional family yeah you know each
other own bed in their own separate room
yes so their house flippers right
getting at oh okay I thought they just
bought a big you paid better attention I
was too busy making jokes I think it was
confirmed to me when he and the eldest
foster daughter when they're like
breaking ship you know is this just a
fixer-upper or is he like bringing her
into the family bidness as a way of
bonding or something yeah because
there's a whole demographic out there
who loves HGTV who loves the flipper God
loves these house flipping shows like
they're gonna love this movie that's an
oddly specific demographic to go after
but you know it could work honestly any
housewife or house husband
someone who's at home during the day
they just put that stuff on loops and
it's oddly satisfying because you see
this just like gross house and then at
the end it's all pretty and like I could
do that and really you couldn't they
should just adopt some foster kids in
every episode they should I mean this
this looks I don't know if I would ever
want to have children but I've
entertained the idea of adopting
children which I don't know I'm bringing
up that in this video but it's pertinent
this looks like it could have a nice
heartwarming cord like I I don't really
know exactly what kind of comedy to
expect out of this because giving me a
lot of different cues some of the more
serious things make me think of
something like the big sick or whatever
it's gonna be really thoughtful and
really heartfelt but then the slapstick
makes me think of Meet the Parents yes
but I feel like having a comedy centered
around you know an adoptive family could
be a really cool thing and could just be
I don't know like it's nice to
acknowledge that in a way that's not
like a your your adopted joke you know
yeah I feel like is just the way we hear
about that most of the time you're
adopted and I'm like it's not a joke
come on you know I agree with you
because there are so many kids in foster
care so it's good to to bring the light
to that and see it from their point of
view as well and like when she calls out
Rose Birds like you're just a white lady
who wants to feel good for adopting some
kids and it's like you know yeah and now
I'm like is the movie gonna actually get
a little bit real cause like I like when
people draw from either like real life
stories like this are just parts of life
that aren't the typical movie set up you
know and and there are movies about
adoptive families as well but you know
it's not like the main
dream premise it does obviously have
some broad comedy stuff in it but I hope
that it does touch on real issues and
give those issues the credence they
deserve you know man I mean cuz like the
kids all look really sweet and that girl
looks super familiar but Mark Wahlberg
and especially Rose Byrne I mean they
can both do comedy but they could both
do drama really well yeah
and I'm actually excited to see Rose
Byrne kind of more on her own cuz like I
thought she was great in bridesmaids but
that's not really her movie and she
isn't really one of the funnier
characters so to have her here being
able to kind of leave more I think will
be a funny thing are we gonna see this
movie we're going tonight we're yeah
we're starting the lineup right now so
if anybody wants to see what's this
called instant instant everybody wants
to see instant family we're lining up
the Chinese Theatre tonight your tents
bring your sleeping bags bring snacks
there's props to whoever in the comments
wrote they tore down the wall to their
hearts because someone I feel like
eventually they're gonna start poaching
YouTube comments for taglines
they should like they're really arty hey
you braid this okay come on working for
my movie come up with our tagline all
right we're hey I wasn't planning on
Mark Wahlberg and then it happen there's
you know an accidental mark wahlberg is
often the best kind I just want an
accidental Mark Wahlberg playlist
whatever that means I want that on a
playlist please send it to me through
wetransfer when it's good I will we will
transfer it to you we have reached I'm
in a band with your comedy persons get
your comedy stamp of approval it's not
necessarily my type of comedy I like
dark comedy because I just could get
dark this could get dark because I feel
like you know things in life that are
really [ __ ] up sometimes you just have
to find the levity in it or else it will
drag you down you know what I mean the
difference between comedy and tragedy is
point of view yeah so those are kind of
comedy I like hitting kids in the head
with baseballs and
the balls not necessarily my gym see
what I like to do is I like to take
moments of levity and find what's [ __ ]
up about them see that's great so my
slapstick movie he's gonna hit that kid
in the face of the basketball they're
gonna have the joke but then there's
gonna be like a whole case opened up
with like social services using this kid
yeah it's just over something petty like
the Clippers that would be mine yes no
that's great I would watch that movie so
yeah subscribe to the reel rejects so
that you can be notified when that movie
and speaking of movies that aren't this
movie her side of the bed go check that
out on the Amazon just google it and
you'll find it probably but don't pirate
it cuz that sucks you can stream it for
free on Amazon Prime which is cool or if
you don't have Prime you can rent it for
3 bucks it helps support indie
filmmakers which is cool and then we can
make more stuff for your viewing
pleasure just so you know like we're all
don't want to make stuff to share with
you all
native community man yeah yeah so go
check that out and also subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get updated every time a review
or a video is out check us out on
patreon full-length TV show watch Long's
Q&A 's exclusive content deleted takes
all kinds of cool stuff great people
over there come check us out and so for
now party people Zamboni